mark zuckerberg is the young and bright
mind behind facebook
and over the years he has been
successful in amassing a wealth
of 111 billion dollars
aside from this mark has been one of the
more
transparent tech moguls as he has
previously taken responsibility
and apologized for data misuse and
security breaches
on top of this he recently even admitted
that facebook
is a left-leaning company despite this
mark zuckerberg remains one of the most
hated billionaires today
in fact some studies show that mark
zuckerberg is
even more hated than donald trump with
only 28 percent having a favorable view
but why
before we get into the bad aspects it
should be mentioned that mark has
several positive aspects about himself
and his company first of all he assigned
the giving pledge
promising to donate 99 of his wealth to
charity
recently facebook has dropped out of the
top 10 places to work list
but nonetheless they are still one of
the best places to work in the world
median compensation has slightly
declined as well
by five percent but the median salary at
facebook is still two hundred twenty
eight thousand
six hundred fifty one dollars per year
which is only beat now by google
with that being said facebook isn't
plagued with bad working conditions
and horrible pay allegations as is the
case with the companies of some
other top billionaires but then why is
mark so hated
well starting off they are sort of a
nice monopoly
when i say that they are a nice monopoly
i don't mean that they are a good
positive monopoly to society but rather
they have a generous approach when it
comes to becoming a monopoly
generally when we think of monopolies we
think of large corporations with
massive amounts of resources and
customers which allows them to undercut
all the competition
but this is not exactly what facebook
does when they see competition brewing
up
they don't try to compete with them
instead they let them grow
and prove their business model and if
they're convinced with the future of the
startup
they make them an offer they can't
refuse oftentimes being
10 to 20 times more than what the
startup is actually worth
for instance facebook bought whatsapp in
which was generating virtually no
revenue at the time
for 22 billion dollars of course
other top tech companies like ebay and
microsoft
have previously made very expensive
acquisitions in the past
however none of them match the magnitude
that facebook overpays at the time of
your acquisitions
this is a win-win situation for the
companies
as facebook grows their position in the
market and the startup is able to cash
out on a valuation
that they likely won't reach for another
decade not to mention
all the struggles in sustaining a likely
money losing business
for another decade for the users however
this is not the best outcome as it no
doubt stifles competition
within the marketplace and this is
especially concerning
given the record privacy concerns
related to facebook
just last summer facebook paid a record
billion dollars to settle privacy
concerns regarding data misuse
one of the largest allegations against
facebook was in conjunction with
cambridge analytica
the story goes that in 2014 facebook
sent out personality quizzes to their
users
but not only did the quiz collect data
on the people
actually taking the quiz but also the
friends and family of the people
taking the quiz in fact only 305
thousand people were estimated to have
downloaded the app
and taken the quiz however facebook was
able to collect
data on 87 million people which is 285
times the people who actually took the
quiz
to make things even worse facebook
turned around and
it is alleged that they sold some of
this data to cambridge analytica
who used it to psychologically profile
u.s voters
despite this circumstantial evidence
cambridge analytica
denied that they used any of this
information to influence the
presidential election
whether they did or not i think we'd
agree that facebook
already took it way too far when they
collected data on
87 million people over 99
of which didn't even take the
personality quiz
though this was one of their most
well-known scandals facebook's
involvement
in politics in general dates back much
further and
is even claimed to have played a
significant role in obama's 2008
election
speaking of politics facebook has been
quite involved in shaping american
politics
even if they're not necessarily
partaking in any illegal activities
for instance they spend millions of
dollars every single quarter towards
lobbying efforts
and they even hired 65 lobbyists who
work the lobby against privacy
legislation within california
and nationally aside from politics it is
also alleged that facebook has run
experimentation
to test how fast negative slash positive
emotions were able to spread amongst
their users
also facebook has been in the spotlight
for various security breaches
and lackluster encryption technology
just two years ago
facebook admitted that a bug may have
been responsible for the private
pictures
of 6.8 million users being posted
similarly in the past facebook has given
their business partners
including amazon and netflix privileged
access to their user data
on the lines of data and influencing
people's emotions
and thoughts facebook has also been
alleged to have censored negative news
relating to democratic party and they
are consequently
under investigation for said censorship
clearly
facebook has a plethora of security and
privacy concerns
anyways moving on from privacy concerns
something that many people may hate even
more about mark zuckerberg
is that the idea for facebook is
arguably stolen
facebook is eerily similar to the
winklevoss twins
connect u and it is likely that mark
zuckerberg
was at least somewhat influenced by
connect u
of course the idea is just one part of
the puzzle
and the more important part is actually
execution
and mark zuckerberg clearly had
outstanding
execution despite this from a moral
perspective
many people dislike the fact that
facebook seems to be a ripoff of connect
u
on the bright side though the winklevoss
twins were only able to get 65 million
dollars from their lawsuit against
facebook
which is a rounding error for the social
media giant the winkle was twins
did turn around and put 11 million
dollars into bitcoin
at 120 dollars per coin and given that
bitcoin is worth over
15 000 per coin today that investment
is worth over 1.3 billion dollars today
so they're not doing bad by any means
anyways before we get into the last
reason and likely
largest reason that zuckerberg is hated
i thought it was worth mentioning that
mark zuckerberg
is one of the youngest billionaires in
the world there's
already generally a disdain for
billionaires as
many people believe that billionaires
are inherently evil
for quote unquote hoarding so much
wealth and
it definitely doesn't help when you
became the youngest billionaire
in the world at the time and have only
grown your wealth since
so i'm sure that the nva slash jealousy
factor
does play at least a small role in the
overall view of mark zuckerberg
finally the last and most major reason
that mark zuckerberg is viewed so
negatively in my opinion is that he
comes off as ingenuine
mark zuckerberg is often called a robot
and a lizard
and these names are understandable as
the guy rarely
ever shows any emotion which makes
everything he says
seem ingenuine and this is likely the
key reason
that he has such a low favorability
score people
may hate steve jobs or the kosh brothers
but
with them it's not a case of being
ingenuine but rather
being genuinely bad with mark zuckerberg
on the other hand
i'm sure he's genuinely trying to be a
good person
but his lack of emotions and personality
often puts people off
and causes them to die his motives for
instance
we previously discussed how facebook was
paying lobbyists
to lighten privacy regulation but at the
same time
zuckerberg wrote an article for the
washington post in which he declared
that the internet needed new rules
regarding privacy
seems like contrary objectives to me
similarly
facebook has even admitted to being
behind a handful of smear campaigns
against competitors as well as critiques
of facebook
this no doubt raises questions about the
ethics and morals of mark zuckerberg
as well as facebook as a whole despite
this seemingly
uncorrectable public image we have
actually already seen this before with
bill gates not too long ago
in the 1980s and 90s bill gates was
often perceived
as an arrogant and ruthless businessman
he was seen as defined to congress
and like every other billionaire crushed
any competition in his way
by either buying them or destroying them
at the time you would see articles
discussing the various anti-trust
violations
microsoft had committed and how flawed
bill gates was
as the ceo and just like zuckerberg
bill gates also became the youngest
billionaire in the world
at the time but since then bill gates
has been able to completely turn around
his public image in 2000 he stepped down
as ceo
and focused all of his efforts into
philanthropy and solving many of the
world's problems
recently there has been a resurgence in
hate for bill gates
but i do think the overall view is still
quite positive
if mark zuckerberg were to follow the
footsteps of bill gates
then he too may be able to slowly shift
the negative public perception
by stepping down and focusing on
philanthropy
like he has promised with his massive
fortune but
in the meantime it's likely that the
questionable activities of facebook
as well as a seemingly ingenuine
demeanor will continue to plague
his leadership do you guys say mark
zuckerberg comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys think
zuckerberg can turn around his public
perception
and consider joining our community
discord to suggest future video ideas
and of course consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys
on the next one